في ظل هذه الظروف الصعبه بنحاول نعيش احنا
مع ابنائنا الصغار مع الكبار لحظات اللي
اللي تواسي تفهم من همتنا وتفهم من شاننا
ان شاء الله في هذه الظروف الصعبه من اجل
انه يعني ما ما تنهز نفوسنا ولا ينقه
اطفالنا ولا يصبع في نفوس
ينوس واجمل منك لم تلد
النساء خلقت مبرا من كل
عيب
كانك قد خلقت كما
تشاء
قمر
قمر قمر سيدنا النبي
قمر ب نزع جيل ان شاء الله جيل يكون قوي
ضد كل هذه الامور اللي بتحصل
معنا جيل ان شاء الله يفهم ايش حقيقه
قضيته بالمور الجميله هذه سواء بال
القعدات الترفيهيه هذه من اجل توصيل رساله
لاطفالنا ايش حقيقه الوضع لكن بطريقه
جميله مابت بيبي بيبي حل ير يا الله
حبيبي شو زكي ومغندر شو
برح نحنا هيك نلاقي بس مجرد ساعه فراغ انه
احنا نقعد مع بعض في هذه الاجواء اجواء
عائليه احنا فعليا فقدناها خلال الحرب وت
كلها محبه وامان ونشرب كبايه هالشاي هذ
نغير نفسيتنا شويه نطلع عن عن مود الشغل
والاصابات والشهداء والحرب والقصف هذا
الشيء بينا جدا لانه فعليا بجدد نفسيتنا
بجد طاقتنا يا حسره العين
والدمع يا جراحنا
المنسي والعالم اللي شافه
وسمع حسوا بوجعنا
شوي عن جد هذه الجلسات يعني لا تمل والله
ولو صحنا ان كل يوم نقعد يعني بس ح نخسرك
شاي والله ابو الامير اه والله صحنا والله
نقعد كل يوم ما بنقصر والله مج الاحتلال
ومجاز الاحتلال ما بتتوقف ابدا بحق
المدنيين ننا لازم نكون احنا صوت غزه قوي
يا غزه اطلعي من عز جرحك وارفعي شاره نصر
رح
ترجعي بجنودنا
عمراني